can a 2022 screen movie really live up
to the high standards set by the
original especially when it's released
in january here's what works and what
doesn't massive spoilers ahead
most people don't come to horror movies
to see awkward romantic scenes
especially between characters the
audience has barely met before sam
returns to woodsboro she has a pretty
uncomfortable i love you moment with her
boyfriend richie the love confession is
the first interaction the audience has
with these characters and it just feels
off given that richie ends up being
amber's secret serial killer boyfriend
the ickiness makes sense but it's a
little early to be that obvious it would
make much more sense to have this kind
of scene take place after sam gets
attacked in the hospital and we've
gotten to know both characters a bit
better but as it stands it only serves
two purposes making fans feel awkward
and showing richie's killer cards a bit
too early let us get invested in a
couple before getting sappy in a horror
film please
back in 1996 sydney and gail didn't
exactly begin their decades-long frenemy
ship with sunshine and roses however
time distance and going through hell
tend to forge a unique bond and this
shines through for gale and sydney in
2022's scream instead of a punch sydney
and gail give each other a hug when they
reunite for the first time in years and
neither are thrilled with the other
woman putting herself back in the path
of the newly minted ghost face behold
the elephant in the room when gail and
sydney meet sam the new final girl gail
scolds her for being icy to sydney but
the team up moments don't stop there
both women have been around the block
more than a few times immediately
clocking that amber is acting shady when
they crash the deadly rager at stu's old
house it doesn't stop gail from getting
stabbed but she tells sydney to finish
the job for dewey of course gail
weathers knows how to make an entrance
and she comes in to save sydney in the
nick of time before sydney gives her
unlikely friend the chance to avenge her
ex-husband's death
herself ever since killing off randy and
scream to and with it any possibility of
a sydney randy relationship gail and
dewey have become scream fans favorite
couple they're a bit of an odd pairing
dewey is a woodsboro lifer while gail
seeks a journalistic reach that extends
far beyond woodsborough's haunting hills
realistically their relationship is
doomed from the start and although it
seems like an inevitability breaking up
gail and dewey offscreen is a disservice
to wes craven he's not here to weigh in
on that decision and the way it plays
out feels cheap and uncharacteristic on
dewey's part sure their reasoning for
the breakup makes sense and that's life
but it's still a bummer gail says that
dewey left her in new york in the middle
of the night like a coward woodsboro
life or not dewey would never their
reunion confrontation scene is gripping
and emotional but it's a lame thing to
do to dewey's character right before his
death
it's no secret that horror has more than
a few toxic damaging cliches that still
exist within the genre scream 2 even
addresses this head on brothers don't
last long in situations like this sure
cameraman joel manages to escape death
by getting the hell out of town but
despite acknowledging this trope scream
2 begins by immediately killing off two
black characters not a good look
ghostface however unlike its
predecessors 2022 scream manages to be
self-aware of the worst stereotypes the
genre has to offer and actually fixes
them the film adequately handles mental
health topics and even boasts a stellar
female-led cast with women who don't
immediately become damsels featuring a
diverse gaggle of teens the movie
manages to subvert the worst horror
tropes all while avoiding being preachy
or taking people out of the film but
even better chad and mindy both survive
ghost faces onslaught to live another
day and in the horror world that's
certainly something to celebrate in fact
almost all of the diverse characters
from the film survive
there's no denying that dewey goes out
with a bang but his death is no less
frustrating the film already takes his
status as a sheriff away forcing him
into retirement which is the reason he
goes hardcore vigilante in the first
place after coming to save tara like a
badass dewey kicks the living daylights
out of ghostface even getting a few
rounds into the killer yet he makes two
vital mistakes that he should have known
better than to do he doesn't take off
ghosty's mask or go in for a head shot
when he has the chance instead he gets
stabbed as blood pulls out of his mouth
and he's spread out on the hospital
floor like a fallen angel with teddy
bears strewn around him the kicker gail
calls while he's bleeding out and her
reaction to his death is heart-wrenching
the one redeeming moment after this
bummer of a sequence comes at the end
when gail refuses to write about the
fame-seeking face killers instead she
wants to write a story about a good man
who used to be the sheriff of woodsboro
however david arquette told looper in an
exclusive interview that dewey was never
originally supposed to survive the first
film so the audience can take solace in
the extra four films we got with him
it's hard to not get a little misty-eyed
at the side of the randy meeks memorial
home theater in the meek's household
following the theme of giving the new
scream characters a connection to the
og's the 2022 film's wonder twins chad
and mindy are the niece and nephew of
our first horror expert randy of course
out of all of the franchise's characters
randy took center stage during the
series most meta moments at least until
his untimely death now in the 2022 film
his niece mindy is here to follow in his
footsteps when it comes to iconic film
moments few can top randy meeks
screaming at a hapless lori strode to
look behind her when he's watching
halloween meanwhile fans and sydney yell
the same thing to randy as ghostface
stalks him keen on keeping up the family
tradition in the 2022 scream mindy
watches the fictionalized stab version
of the very same scene repeating his
oblivious performance as she yells at
randy to turn around while ghostface
lurks in the room she's now reached a
third level of meta but given her
uncle's fate she should really know
better the movies just aren't the same
without randy and the homage is a
welcome touch
ah yes the killer reveal everyone has
been waiting for since tara's landline
first rang scream gets even more meta
than usual when richie and amber out
themselves as woodsboro's latest
dastardly duo so what's the deal with
richie and amber's unlikely homicidal
pairing oh they just hate the
in-universe stab sequels adapted from
gale's original books yep that's it they
met on a stab message board of all
places before richie stalked and seduced
sam of course he takes a minute out of
his very busy stabbing schedule to [ __ ]
shame sam the woman he actively
manipulated and that's not even covering
the creepy age difference between him
and tara like most of the ghostface
killers they're whiny about their origin
story complaining that no one takes a
true fan seriously essentially their
murder spree is a twisted director's cut
they concoct to make a better movie that
honors the original just go to film
school you creeps the reveal is a
mixture of an epic yet fairly
predictable plot twist topped off with
lackluster motives dewey even calls the
plot twist right at the very beginning
it's always the love interest
as far as horror villains go ghostface
is a simple killer he torments some
hapless teenagers on the phone and a
discount costume from the corner store
then gets stabby when people don't want
to play his deadly game as far as bells
and whistles go his kills don't have a
whole lot of thrills that's what makes
the screen franchise good it knows
exactly what it is and doesn't need to
prove anything with an onslaught of cgi
and special effects occasionally however
the series does seem to feel the need to
add some extra oomph to the kills gail
and sydney's partnership comes into play
when the duo takes on one half of
ghostface amber amber seems to bite the
dust after a fiery collision with a gas
stove later on in arguably the most
badass scene of the series sydney hands
the gun to tara who takes the kill shot
when a flaming amber barrels into the
room
there's nothing more iconic in the
scream franchise than ghostface's voice
why because it isn't all that sinister
when ghostface calls casey in the
original scream he seems like you're a
garden-variety dude who has seen one too
many horror films his voice alone
doesn't exactly scream serial killer no
you're doing so well
we can't stop now
by keeping ghostface's voice pitched at
a relatively normal level he has been
able to dupe people into staying on the
line longer sometimes his victims don't
even know it's actually him that level
of suspense and deception has worked
exceptionally well for the character for
decades and up to this point it's a
well-established character trait yet
instead of following suit the 2022 film
goes for a more modern approach lowering
ghostface's voice and making him sound
immediately threatening when you like to
play a game tara it's a surprise tara
stays on the phone with this guy past
the 22nd mark the movie does justice to
the original film in many ways but
ghostface's vocal tweaks distract from
what is otherwise a stellar take on the
classic villain
the first scream film reached iconic
status because of a cast that largely
perished in that very same movie and due
to the ever revolving slate of villains
in the franchise the sequels have never
quite lived up however series fans are
met with an epic surprise when skeet
ulrich crashes the woodsboro party
returning as billy loomis no he doesn't
get a resurrection in physical form but
viewers discover that billy didn't only
leave dead bodies behind in scream as it
turns out he's the biological father of
the new final girl sam we can chuck her
conception up to bad high school
decisions throughout the film we watch
sam grappling with this revelation years
after the reveal and her trauma
manifests itself as a hallucination of
dear old dead dad however the stakes are
raised when richie tries to kill her and
she sees a vision of billy showing her
where a knife is on the ground up until
this point billy is a hostile
representation of her own self-hatred
regarding her mental health and genes
but she accepts herself in this moment
in addition to the fun cameo from ulrich
it's a nice redemption moment for sam in
that your genealogy or mental health
doesn't define who you are power
typically demonizes mental illness but
this moment is a nice change of pace
the 2022 scream is a compelling mashup
between the legacy and new cast the new
film offers perfect closure for the
franchise and it would be the perfect
ending if they stopped here the beauty
of scream and its sequels hinges on the
fact that the writers never rebooted the
movie franchise with a new final girl
the 2022 scream is a phenomenal homage
but most fans don't want woodsboro
without sydney prescott given how many
characters survive this movie the film
sets up the franchise for an overhaul
that could continue for another 25 years
with a new cast but that will only add
scream to the list of franchises watered
down by too many sequels the movie
offers closure for the legacy characters
and teases the future of ghostface but
nobody needs to see that play out on
screen the 2015 scream tv series was a
great way to keep the franchise alive
without overshadowing the films but
scream movies that don't focus on sydney
just feel wrong
wes craven director of the original
scream film is nothing short of a horror
legend his films are so ingrained in pop
culture that even horror's biggest
haters can name characters like freddy
krueger and ghostface craven reinvented
the horror genre and was an invaluable
element of some of the best satirical
and deconstructed horror the genre has
ever seen while many horror franchises
lose their director after the first or
second films craven stood by scream up
until his death in 2015. craven loved
this franchise just as much as its
dedicated fans and despite his passing
you can feel his presence throughout the
2022 film nev campbell said during an
exclusive interview with looper
discussing doing the fifth film without
craven he was talked about every day and
we were always discussing would west do
it this way would he do it that way the
directors wanted that input because
they're uber fans of his they became
directors because of wes she praised the
final product adding quote i really
think they've done him right i think wes
would be proud just as the movie honors
its fallen characters 2022's scream
dedicates itself to craven with two
words four wes dylan minnette even plays
a character named wes another nod to the
late great filmmaker all in all no fan
watching the movie can deny that wes
craven's legacy and energy lives on in
the movie and that's all fans could hope
for
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you